two million face masks protective
clothing and disinfectant confiscated by
the Spanish police all these goods were
stolen their market value around five
million euros the fraudsters intended to
repackage everything in the storage
space in Santiago de Compostela to hide
the items origin Europol the European
Police Authority has had its hands full
for weeks three big developments
the first one is counterfeiting goods
that is really the booming sector
secondly we see a real shift in
cybercrime and thirdly the abuse of
vulnerable groups that other three big
areas we detected until now the door of
special interest for organized crime
groups counterfeit face masks like these
confiscated by Italian police are being
sold online at exaggerated prices but
they were not produced to medical
standards in a sterile environment
Europol has already taken down more than
2,500 websites and online shops
detaining more than 120 people behind
them criminal enterprises have become
highly creative in the pandemic what we
see organized crime group D they use the
opportunity because they use the fear of
the people and they used effect that
people needs answers to their questions
and that they want to protect themselves
but it's not just criminals taking
advantage of people's fear the NRA the
American gun lobby has launched an
online campaign encouraging people to
arm themselves I am one of the millions
of Americans
who is vulnerable to the deadly
coronavirus I hope I survive the
coronavirus that's up to God what's in
my control is how I defend myself if
things go from bad to worse you might be
wondering why I'm holding this
[Music]
in March Americans bought two and a half
million weapons that's 85 percent more
than a year ago but the fear of
increased criminal activity during this
crisis is not matched by actual figures
according to police in most major cities
worldwide even New York or Los Angeles
there's been a dramatic drop in the
number of crimes including murder and
break-ins but on the italian island of
sicily and in other countries criminals
are taking advantage of people's
financial strain and other difficulties
they set out to plunder supermarkets
which is why police have been stationed
to protect them the mayor of Naples has
warned that wherever citizens are unable
to pay their bills because of the
lockdown the Mafia is mercilessly
stepping in to take advantage of the
situation
I'm not joined by Lucia bird she's
senior analyst at the Global Initiative
against transnational organized crime
she's based in London hello Lucia
how are coronavirus lockdowns impacting
organized crime well for some criminal
groups covet presents an opportunity for
others an operational challenge criminal
groups are extremely flexible and they
move towards where the greatest profits
are and as we've heard medical masks are
one of these areas and for example we've
seen a number of dark net accounts
originating in China that traditionally
sold synthetic drugs now advertising
masks as the chemicals required to
manufacture the illicit drugs have
become more expensive due to Cobras
supply chain restrictions masks have
become newly profitable but for some
groups they've seen their traditional
revenues dry up for example for many
gangs in Central America
extortion is a key source of revenue
where they take a percentage of the
profits of businesses in exchange for
protection
however with covert restrictions
non-essential businesses have shut and
gang members cannot go to collect the
extortion payments so law enforce
have trapped a shift into other
activities to plug this revenue gap like
drugs trafficking or they're predicting
move into cybercrime yeah and speaking
of cybercrime you see the --use of law
enforcement agency Europol says that
there's been a spike in cybercrime why
would that be happening there are a
number of reasons kovat and the public
fear that it has created offers an
opportunity for cyber criminals
including in the form of phishing scams
which we've seen a huge surge of now
we've seen this happen with other public
health emergencies like Ebola or SARS
but kovat is unprecedented global
further much of cyber crime requires
relatively limited tech skills you can
buy a fishing kit online for as little
as $50 so it is feasible for some
criminal actors who see their usual
activities become more difficult to move
into cybercrime lissa very quickly how
about what's going on in terms of human
trafficking
so with human trafficking the
vulnerability of many is set to increase
and therefore their exploitation by
criminal groups with human smuggling
which is slightly different and is more
to do with a regular migration we've
seen a temporary decrease in activity
due to movement restrictions but also
fear of contagion among smugglers and
migrants we've seen some changes in
routes so for example in Morocco land
routes have almost completely stopped
but maritime routes almost certainly
smuggler facilitated continue and we may
see some that we're moving by land shift
to see further we'll see lots of
migrants stuck in transit and then they
run out of funds because this wasn't
planned for him budgets and become
highly vulnerable to exploitation by
criminal groups finally although we may
see this temporary lull the drivers for
movement have not disappeared in fact
post covert and the many livelihoods
disappeared they may well have increased
so we're expecting surge in movement
much of it irregular given that legal
pathways are shrinking much of it
smuggler facilitated and this means a
swelling of smuggler profits let's see
bird in London thank you